what is going on there citizens the
reject Nation we are back for One Piece
episode three today rejoined by Aaron
Alexander Aaron how are you Alexander
I am doing good that's that's good that is
Baseline we have created on camera Rapport
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead leave
a like on this video that would be very much
appreciated also subscribe and click that
notification Bell to get notified when our
next reaction from One Piece is up here on
the channel as always full-length Reaction
watch along where you sing with your own
copy oh face the battle for our super sex
rejects over and on patreon page recover several
things exclusive over there reaction Watchdogs
recruited how does Eminem do it thank
you damn these highlights let's get to it
thank you
the Pirates are coming
Pirates the players are coming oh no way his whole
life the boy who cried wolf that's hilarious there
are no Pirates haven't been in years that's where
you're wrong I know they're coming the Great
Captain usop will protect you this place is called
real Street r-e-e-l ah you should live there
it's ready what is it or Jolly Roger every
pirate crew has to have one and now we do
they brought it to life Aaron from the
anime we haven't seen we've probably
brought it to life they did it I'm sure
they're all crying tears of joy right now
we're taking in water what did you do I didn't
do anything we're gonna need a better ship if
we want to make it to the Grand mine worthy
of the straw hat crew Like Straw Hat goofy
famous Tick Tock sensation what a reference
so where do we get that our closest bet is
the gecko Islands we can probably make it there
before our ship sinks those the gecko islands
where that kid is who's been exclaiming
for years that the Pirates are coming
prove yourself if you're gonna sail under me
I love the juxtaposition on the color schemes
where like when you're with our crew the straw
hat it's like colorful here it's just like so
black and white and gray and washed out yeah
very plain I'm trying to do this clean look
thing hey what do you think you're doing
I already tied that knot that would have
slipped I'm just trying just trying to show me up
uh oh never mind I don't think he's gonna become
a hero no it's still a little [__] which one of
you secured this rigging he did Sir is that true
wow so if I not son you've spent time at Sea
yes sir I have why don't you come with me
what about me I would have hoped your
father would have taught you better
Marine would figure that Bounty anyway
you're kind of a wanted man yourself now
wow what is fish lens kind
of deals what's going on here
uh rage shot Fresh Start you're
right what is this is crazy
it's like the drug cam what's going on
so I feel like there's something watching them
yeah I get that feeling oh I guess Buggy's
still in this little runt nobody makes a
fool of Buddy the clown oh venomous I was
gonna team up with someone Boogie the Clown
holy [__] what is this what in the shark man is
this harlong wants a word
and I don't take requests
okay that is a superpower right there
that is beautiful is that their ship
or the classic ship I don't know but
I hope so I like it like the the goat design
it's finding love for the ship yeah real beauty
huh he taking that thing you can talk no over here
Canon Dex 4 and aft is you fast the fastest
is he bullshitting the owner of the ship just
happens to be my closest friend in the world she
owns the whole Shipyard she's rich rich I'm sure
you can strike a deal with her they're going
to piss him off they're going to piss off a lot
it is you play a little so good I can't
tell if you've taken such a liking to
him or just wants to use him because
he thinks he can get to the Pirates
maybe a little of both let's see
if you can do more than tie knots
I've never seen a house this big before
great transition guys giving me an open
invitation to drop out anytime I want
wow look at the panda and the tiger
oops you know there's actually a
more exclusive interest back this way
he is not invited you ain't
welcome here you know it I
know nothing of this sort I'm here
to give Kyle an extra special gift
well hello there sick what's going on with you
in here happy birthday you
remember this of course I did no
well where do I know this guy from I brought
some of my crew is he talking about us you
almost stay for dinner when do we eat not dressed
like that you will bathe and change before dinner
how horrible I don't know I feel like there's
something percolating here there's something soon
you can't trust don't trust those eyes I
don't trust that hair of his it's too oily
I wanted to give you your birthday present
are they lovers yeah a giant Pearl uh
huh my ship almost capsizing to find it
a child a goldfish [__]
voice down oh she is sick
thank you blue tea fascinating when you've
been sick as long as I have you get used to
it because tea is the only thing that makes me
feel better or is the tea making her sick I'll
keep going on these Grand Adventures as long
as you want to hear them I wouldn't miss them
for the world oh I like them together
they have good chemistry they're cute
hey does that Butler seem familiar to
you guys yes I was saying the same thing
rich people don't have the same emotions
we do the stuff this stuff doesn't make
her feel lonely and makes her feel important yes
I identify very much so um I'm sure we can work
out a way to get that shipped rich people don't
stay Rich by giving things away yes I identify
I bet I can convince Kaya to give us that ship
and when you can't we go with your plan steal
one and move on you're on there's something
so ethereal about the way this episode in
particular shot is it feels like a fever
dreams like yeah strange the the sets and
I'm trying to understand the purpose of it
stepping into like a certain kind of world
feels very Alice in Wonderland to me yeah yeah
I definitely feel that I had nothing when your
parents took me in it has been an honor to
repay their kindness and yours by serving
you these past three years oh my god did you
kill yourself he wants the money hey that's
all you idiot it's a chef's reflex you want to
poison yourself do you hear that preparations
just keeping her sick he is villainous what is
this I'm sorry sir it won't happen again killer
everything must be
must be of all nights oh my God it's
going to be a massive poison Fest game
you're overthinking things son you won't
win Wars if you keep playing defensive
very good sir you just keep getting
in your own way oh he does like him
two minutes he wants to make him his protege
smartness smart to have the ticking time clock
let's take a look at the panel yeah yeah
I love when they can make a scene like this
engaging when you don't even know the rules right
right I don't know what's happening one
wait what you did it these are so good
I know right reminds me of that one time I
slayed a dragon cooked it over an open flame
true story bro you look absolutely radiant no
I'm so glad you could make it what A peculiar
episode you look familiar highly doubtful
so funky bar mirror ball Island funky bomb
there are matters concerning
the transfer of ownership of
the shipyard we need to discuss oh God
but she has prepared your special soup ew
tonight at midnight I will become
the soldier we want to buy the
ship from you I said mentioned
that your Sailors we're Pirates
honest to a fault we have already defeated an evil
clown rated a Marine base and
taken down a captive with an ax
we're just getting started oh my God what are
you doing being a pirate has been my dream
he just doesn't understand how other
people it's over at the end of the journey
the one piece and they come King of the Pirates
you have a beautiful ship out there a caramel with
a sheep figurehead it spoke to me that's the ship
we need to follow our dreams I promise you we'll
take care of it oh my God she's gonna say yes
so inspiring we spotted the wreckage of an
abandoned Sloop I found this on board they
lost it already dang that was so quick I want
those pirates found yes sir not you him nepotism
can only get you so far his hair reminds me
of the villain from Puss in Boots too haven't
seen it oh [__] you should it's really good
I have run this estate for Miss Kaya for years
so it is only natural that she should ask me to
run the family business prick then she can tell
me herself oh dude you're signing your death
wish death warrant right now here it is murder
oh oh he's fast he's a quicksman under the hand
through the heart oh no Edward scissors oh my God
cool look though that's like two villains in a
row have like the the blades at the end of the
hands because buggy did it too with his yeah
little fists it's cool look it is pretty dope
20 million oh he cut it up I'm here to remind you
of your place in the food chain what are long baby
you don't gotta worry about me I'm Small Potatoes
I love their designs you know who's out there
really disrespecting you it's that little rubber
prick in a straw hat goes by the name of Lucy oh
nice Luffy's building quite the reputation I
help you find Luffy from villain to henchmen
it's hell do you have to do that I've got eyes
and ears everywhere I don't know I feel like he's
got something clever I think I think he can outwit
this in some way okay okay I feel like this Show's
kind of breaking him down and then by the end of
the season he'll be like oh [__] he's something
to really fear oh like he's gonna be like the joke
of the show and then he's gonna come on top okay
yeah
the one room she shouldn't have gone into
what are you doing is everything right
the house is so massive I was just trying
to find the bathroom with the pillowcase
I'm very discreet you are a pirate after all I
hate Pirates I won't apologize for that I find
some of the decor to be a bit gaudy I prefer to
donated to charity I'm not charity so you're not
you're not charity but take it I give it to
you because you need help it's not as fun now
Kai are you okay everyone's so carefully
around me like one wrong move and I'll
break I don't want your pity well
you won't get it then you're a [__]
Kaya needs me is your girlfriend or something is
it for me no no we've known each other for years
ever since his mother died it was a transition
he likes to come around and tell me all about
his Brave exploits and Grand Adventures she's
more like my best friend that's how you love
her so much your parents what happened to them
they died at Sea I couldn't even go through
their belongings who do you think the parents
are locked up the memories in the East wing
just her parents just her parents some
some fools that died but see I'm actually
dead maybe they just got lost you're not
very good at this friends thing are you
she has the best laughing but we're just friends
come on uncover the secret great shot got
it from my dad he's a notorious pirate oh
he left for a life at Sea when I was just a
baby but I thought he feared to me back one
day oh so he would say the Pirates are coming
was he like getting excited about his dad yeah
interesting yeah something great I know him he's
a part of shit's crew what which one was he the
guy with the goggles if you guys are going to
talk about feelings I'm really gonna need a
drink oh there's a wine cellar in the basement
the press it all once you tell me that before
you coming nope this is every food got everything
I need right here oh God don't get sick Luffy
are you just drinking random Blue Goop hey I'm
pretty sure they keep the good stuff over here
oh it's a good thing the butler tried to hide the
body five blades I think I've seen this before
okay so he's fought him oh not a wanted poster
your crew captain of the black cat Pirates oh
cool reveal okay wait Cloud
door is a pirate the Dead
one man he's been playing those super long game
oh if he's thinking that ball swords you know he's
serious you know you mean
business no what the [__]
quick because the slingshot wait are
they like what are they snakes snake
people yeah they got the fangs she had
fangs too yeah oh snap and their hiss
was very specific why don't you join me
for breakfast tomorrow your friends too
oh she's so sweet don't like Claude or
anyone for that matter run your life
you're stronger than you think don't forget
your pillow oh my God I'm in love with her
she's so sweet is she gonna put the [__] back
oh she putting the [__] back putting it back
damn he's like way knocked out from that bottle
hit right oh they actually threw him in there
oh now no Trace Left Behind don't be dumb oh
my God he's gonna do like a sword climb thing
oh that'd be dope this is the one in his mouth
going up the mountain I'm going up the wall s
wait what what's happening
he's the boy who cried wolf
no one will believe him
did it too many times but you do
know that even if he doesn't come
he will I know he will then you'll start
feeling better oh of course you were
Mom oh is
Pirates are here I'm gonna guess yes they really
are why won't anybody believe me oh poor guy
oh [__] I believe you wow I love the
complexity of this ah [__] dang dab
I was really I was wonderfully complex right there
all right well this is going to be like a super
continuation the next one will be like a it seemed
like a word because it's like a two-parter because
each one's kind of been contained even though it's
a chapter but this feels like one section of this
larger story yeah what was the name of the the
pirate who took um buggy buddy buggy buggy I don't
know shark man yeah I feel like he's probably
gonna be the main villain I can see that yeah
he's got a bit of that like Davy Jones quality um
yeah I think I'm on the street yeah Street Jones
yeah no I think it might be like it'll be coming
the heads of the guy who's like the main Marine
who's manipulating the kid and that the shark
guy yeah and those would be like the the finale
villains what did you think of the episode that
was good I really enjoyed it uh I liked getting
to meet our our new potential uh crew member with
uh with usop because we spent a lot of time for
him for not to be joining the team yeah and yeah
like the kind of how you were commenting on the
episode uh throughout like the aesthetic of it
was really cool had a lot of really cool shots
in it and yeah I think that you know we really got
to focus on on usab got to get a little bit more
like Nami like into you know her her state of mind
and kind of grow her character a little bit more
um yeah I feel like even though they're in the
episode I feel like as far as development goes
Luffy and Zoro kind of took a back seat and like
let us focus on these other characters but yeah
really a really dug it um yeah the aesthetic was
really cool kind of how you're calling out and
yeah we're just getting to see more of this world
like the pieces are coming together things are
moving and grooving you know and yeah we're gonna
see what what Buggy's up to because I feel like
he's not going to be uh I thought he's gonna be
a one note villain or like a one like villain of
the week kind of thing but then I was surprised
to see him pop back up and yeah no I enjoy the
episode it's like it's part one it's like a
better Fuller feelings once we see how this
uh section of the arc wraps up yeah I like
what they're doing buggy because it I think
they're they're stripping him down and then
they're rebuilding him back up which I think
is going to be really cool I feel like he'll
be he'll amount to something really important
um as opposed to just like another villain
or or a threat another clown villain and the
wide Pantheon of Ip that we have out here so
I think that that's a cool way to set him up
and and uh I'm loving what they're I'm just
so bad with names who's the Marine Cadet guy
um Lobby it was like Corey Kobe Kobe Kobe
Kobe yeah yeah yeah uh with Kobe I love the
build up there I actually didn't anticipate
that happening with the everything just feels
like very multi-layered with the evil Cadet
guy he doesn't even like he comes across evil
blah blah is he really evil yet he hasn't really
done anything evil he's just kind of doing his
job right now yeah yeah you know but you're like
there's something like really messed up about I
don't trust him I feel like he's manipulating
that kid I mean it feels like he's manipulated
him because he's the one he knows that he can use
him to get to the Pirates yeah um but he's getting
him to buy into him with trust as opposed to the
way that because I feel like they're doing this
kind of uh underlying thread with him where when
you first meet him he's with that one pirate woman
who was just using and abusing him and now he's
being used again but in a way that he'll think
is respectable and endearing when really he's
just being used yeah but it also creates a cool
complexity for him you may say that word a lot
he creates a cool complexity for him because he
he has that relationship with Luffy he knows that
hey like yeah I know bad Powers but Luffy's not
one part of this category that you're hunting yeah
somebody is the first person who's ever kind to
him but he's also building up the Loyalty with the
Marines which is going to make his decision make
it even harder so I like that and it also gives
like someone who's like that timid to uh grow I
think is really neat and then of course uh yeah
I mean everything here at the house I think was
really interesting it was really odd strange weird
eccentricities throughout I love the twist that
we got with the the reveal of who the butler
is as opposed to just another Butler guy who
wants to inherit the fortune like it was a little
predictable of what the twist would be on what
he's really trying to do but then the reveal it oh
like he's actually some like you know another one
of them Supernatural Pirate characters like oh
okay I didn't actually see that coming that was
clever I was really cleverly done and I I love the
performance so again terrible names what's what's
the guy's name the guy who just met hung out with
the whole time us up Usopp loved it I thought he
was great uh for there's so much uh an adventure
spirit that you can feel compliments Luffy in a
way where he could see them becoming like really
great friends oh yeah and I like the people who
keep joining the band the band of Misfits because
you could you get that that tangible feeling that
Luffy is constantly inspiring and in a way where
he might not even intend to sometimes like he
knows how to motivate he knows how to connect and
then there are times where you know even in the
most hardened shell of people will end up coming
along the ride with him yeah it's his his naive
optimism and like his lack of social awareness
that makes him so endearing love it yeah yeah he
really feels like a live-action anime character
that's brought to life and I was like wow I
feel like it's the first time I've seen that that
archetype truly brought and it's like it works yes
yeah there's some good setups I mean we're gonna
watch the next episode right away uh you know
even though we're keeping this discussion short
like a really long discussion will definitely be
reserved for the finale mm-hmm definitely
but quick thoughts on that I think yeah
good music and I think what they're well say
too is like they're doing a really great job
completely shifting where your focus is going
every episode and they have a challenge on their
hands and they introduce a set of new characters
every episode and to get you to buy into it and be
interested in it and they're doing a really good
job on that because like last week or in the last
week last episode was buggy buddy buggy buggy
God damn it buggy and then this episode you're
reading this like Alice in Wonderland type of of
flair to it and with a whole new set of characters
and then like spoiled sick rich girl she was
even interesting I really loved her performance
she's really there's something very melancholic
and sweet about her I really enjoyed her a lot
and and you watch how she affects Nami and you
get these teases of where growth can be I think
they're doing a a really excellent job and and
on top of that too one thing we haven't really
talked about is like just the World building
is great oh fantastic there's like a phenomenal
World building here uh it's and I think a lot of
times when you're introducing when you're trying
to do an adaptation of stuff that's kind of
where they just get way too bogged down and
they they're they're letting the world building
sort of naturally happen by reactions and getting
to see people and societies of how they respond
to things no it feels all feels organic they're
telling you the information you need to know
rather than overloading you with just lore
for Laura's sake a thousand percent and yeah
I think that the way that it's playing out
it it's playing out in a way that's organic
but also makes you intrigued to want to know
more that's who want to know all these extra
details like we got to know that usop's Dad was
with Luffy and then that uh what the what's
the girl's name I don't remember her name
yeah right because the swords and stuff
he said he's your favorite character he
is my favorite character so far he's got such a
great presence it's cool and and I I think the
on-camera chemistry between him and Luffy are
phenomenal like with just when you put them in
the same frame you're like there's such a good
pairing between them I imagine that's what it's
like one of the anime maybe I don't I don't know
what the Dynamics are but with them two on screen
together there's such opposite personalities
yet they fit yeah and that's that's when you
got like magic in a bottle with your cast where
you're like oh yeah they're so different they
look different they behave different one's
full of optimism and wonder the other one is
completely jaded and you know and I love love
it yeah uh I'm really enjoying the show it's
a really good show man yeah alrighty guys
what do you think about episode three keep
a lookout for episode four reaction they just
take some time to put together you know so uh
keep a look at we're trying to do like an every
other day upload thank you so much for being
here again thank you all join our patreon we'll
catch you all soon see you in just a little bit